what's good goodbye what is good thank
you for having me big shout out to
everybody in the back I see you up there
love you too let's get into it
all right thank you so my plan here
actually is to do quite a bit of QA
because the reality is the more I do
this the more I realize how simplistic
my point of view on marketing and
entrepreneurship and business actually
is you know I a lot of times compare
business and entrepreneurship and
marketing to working out or health you
know the reality is is trillions of
dollars are being spent on looking
better feeling better but the reality is
is eating well and working out at the
gym every day is the actual answer yet
people are looking for celery or apple
vinegar or surgery to execute that for
them and the reality is is that's
basically how I see business the reality
is it's actually quite simple and more
importantly for everybody in this room
we are here during an extremely special
time because this device is wildly
underrated by all of us in this room
this is a far bigger deal than I think
we can understand how many people here
are oh are older than 40 years old
raise your hands I'll raise mine so for
the people that just raised their hands
you're aware because we lived in the
world pre-internet you're aware how
remarkable the internet actually is for
the people in this room how many people
under 30 raise your hands
no concept you've had it so good which
is amazing I love it
the reality is is that it's difficult
for you even to know how much
opportunity you actually have because
you've only known a world with the
the Internet is one of the stunning
all-time most important innovations to
hit the human race it has created a
scenario where I can be in New York
producing content on a video and many
people how many people here by show
viens consume my content how many people
[Music]
[Applause]
for this many people to consume my
content at the volume of the content
that I put out 30 years ago would have
required me to either buy a media
company for hundreds of millions of
dollars or get lucky that I got chosen
to star in a show that went global it
was inconceivable yet every single
person here can leave this conference
and make a video or a picture or write
words on two platforms right now
LinkedIn and tic toc have no awareness
nobody knows who you are
you haven't started yet or if you have
you're bad at it and yet
tick tock and LinkedIn with no audience
will reward you and have more people see
it because there's so many people paying
attention to it yet there's not enough
content being put in and so you get
organic reach at scale when I see that
it reminds me of everything I've ever
done since I've been a professional when
I started building my family's wine
business for them it was email it was
Google AdWords later it was Google
search organic for me and then when my
career really took a different change it
was YouTube and Twitter
it was then Facebook snap Instagram my
friends this has now been going on for a
long time and social media it's been
going on for over a decade the concept
is very simple there is a tension and
then there's what you say for everybody
in this conference the key is to figure
out how they communicate
are you good at video are you good at
audio are you good at the written word I
promise you for the far majority of you
the biggest breakthrough you could
possibly have at this conference is to
figure out what kind of communicator are
you because everybody aspires for video
because that's what we're all paying
attention to yet some people here are
remarkable writers but they shy away
from it because they don't think that's
the way to break through they think
there's rules here's the rules if you're
unable to communicate you can't be heard
then nobody knows what you've got to
sell whether you're selling funding for
a charity or running for government or a
business communication is the variable
communication is the variable by the way
it's always been that way
what's remarkable is every single person
in this room now can do it my bigger
question is why aren't you there is no
way that what I just said is something
that is so profound I think everybody
here who here does not have a smartphone
raise your hand good nobody oh really is
that true
what are you just joking you don't have
a smartphone please come up here you're
like I want to meet you sir please come
up here get up here get up here I'm not
I'm not finishing to talk until you get
up here
Dubai this is an amazing moment in our
lives
this man does not own a smartphone it is
more likely that an alien comes from
space and joins me get up here get up
here uh-huh
I I believe it's more likely an alien
what's your name Xion so nice to meet
you let's clap it up for this legend
legend no smartphone you did have one at
some point it did and how long ago did
you get rid of it ten days ago why good
for you laptop laptop good for you my
friend thank you real pleasure thanks
for being here let's clap it up now for
the rest of us
it's funny this may be interesting to a
lot of you because one of things I
always talk about his patience I've been
doing this a long time they weren't as
big of conferences but I remember when I
was doing conferences and I would talk
about smart phones and most of the room
did not have one
they had a pager you know and and how
many people here had a blackberry
raise your hands remember when you said
you would never get an iPhone because
you needed the buttons this is what I do
for a living what I do for a living is I
pay attention to people 24/7 365 for all
the talking I do every minute you don't
see me I'm listening I'm watching people
are very good at saying what they won't
do but I already know they will there
are people in this audience who right
now in their head say they will never
get on tick-tock and I know you will
this is what I spend my time on this is
what I spend my time on because since I
was a little child
I've been chasing your attention when I
was selling lemonade I didn't sell the
lemonade
I made the signs and I put the signs on
the trees and the poles when I worked
baseball card shows I spent hours
forming my table to try to figure out
how to stop you at my table not the
persons next when I worked in my dad's
liquor store and I stood behind the
register when I was supposed to ring up
people I would watch people walk into
the store and I would watch which aisle
they would go to what bottle they would
grab why it's why I read all your DMS
and your texts everybody gives me a lot
of credit carriers so tonight thank you
for replying thank you for liking it's
amazing No thank you for commenting it
gives me insight I understand I listen I
listen here's what I can tell you about
people the big things that are happening
in our society number one people value
time over everything consciously and
subconsciously time convenience wins all
the time convenience we do not want to
do things that we know can be done
faster
people talk about privacy we all give up
privacy every day for convenience speed
speed
no friction why do I produce content on
every platform because I want you to
consume it how you want to consume it
you want to listen to a podcast while
you run I'm here you're a good reader
and want to read on LinkedIn I'm here
you want to put it on your Apple TV and
throw it up and watch YouTube on your
television I'm here short here long here
no friction people sit around they have
all these big ambitions to be an
influencer or to build a big business
and then they pick one platform and
that's where they spend all their time
do you know many people here would be in
big trouble if Instagram disappeared
tomorrow how can you be reliant on one
platform Tila Tequila and Dane Cook one
on myspace they didn't respect Facebook
and Twitter that was a mistake
YouTube snap they have been flow they
haven't flow but like real estate but
like real estate when there's a new
platform that has a lot of attention
it's a good deal when you can buy
beachfront property you can buy
beachfront property
it goes up if that area becomes big I
spend an enormous amount of time looking
at underpriced attention the way that
people look at under priced real estate
I believe the current under priced
attention in the world is LinkedIn and
tik-tok when I wrote crush it crushing
it excuse me my last book the yellow one
right there I just wrote that 18 months
ago not a mention of tick-tock and link
did not a mention I because I saw a lot
of hands go up and that made me feel
really good one more time how many
people consume my content thank you so
so you guys know that I say the same
thing over and over I'm showing you
videos from eight years ago when I had a
bad haircut and was a little chubbier
saying the same [ __ ]
that will never change hard work
kindness caring about your employees
always thinking about the customer it's
all gonna stay the same forever until I
die what won't be the same
is how important snapchat is versus
Facebook versus YouTube versus Instagram
it always will above this is why I want
you guys to listen very carefully to me
one of the most fascinating things that
have happened in the world in the last
10 years is that real celebrities 10
years ago made fun of YouTube
celebrities Instagram celebrities
podcasts celebrities real models real
models seven years ago made fun of
Instagram models until they didn't I'm
gonna say something that's very
important to me and everybody in this
room creating content on social networks
for everybody in this room regardless if
you're part of the ministry whether
you're in business and to business b2b
whether you're b2c whether you're part
of the government whether you're an
individual for every person in this room
from every angle from every person
creating content on social networks at
scale is the single great opportunity in
our society and everybody in this room
everybody including me will regret in 15
years not making more because you do
understand other technologies are coming
you do understand that when voice comes
along and Google home and Apple home and
Alexa when voice comes we're not gonna
be looking at our phone as much just
like that gentleman realizes maybe I
don't have to have it when you can say
Alexa where's the best restaurant Alexa
send me toilet paper Google what's the
weather think about all the things you
go to your phone that takes 25 seconds
but Alexa can answer in two
you will choose Alexa over your phone
remember I told you when we do that we
will be reliant on your brand not being
discovered in Explorer or showing up
third on Google this is a very important
time in communication history the reason
you're seeing things like America and
London and India and all sorts of things
happening in the world different things
that we didn't expect is because of
communication communication has always
been the forefront of what happens in
the world almost everything you believe
right now was put into your head by your
parent by a piece of content by
something else my friends please do not
waste this conference the fact that we
have this time together to not let this
be the time that you finally hear me
you've been listening to my content but
you don't hear me you've been listening
to my content but you don't live what
I'm telling you to do why because
there's a much bigger thing that's going
on then what platform you should post on
or how often it's called self-esteem the
single most important thing that I think
about these days is that I am blown away
by the level of insecurity there is in
our society we have so much insecurity
that Instagram had to take likes away
because you're not capable of actually
talking about what you actually want to
talk about you are so addicted to other
people's opinions that you start posting
only things that you think will get
likes not what you actually want to talk
about this is very important thank you
it's very important
thank you it's very important I promise
you the reason that I stand on stage is
because the self-esteem and parenting
that my mother put into my body period
period the way she raised me around
putting kindness and hard work but also
no entitlement not worrying about what
people said about me is imperative let
me tell you what the biggest
vulnerability for most people here is
about social media and content you enjoy
the cheering too much the reason this is
an interesting game is you love it when
you post something and people say you
look pretty or that was a good shot or
you're funny or that was brilliant
you take compliments too high so when
people come in and say you look ugly or
you're stupid or you're wrong
you take push back too deep I and all
the people that I see who are winning
don't take the compliments or the
insults every day on my content there's
comments that say you suck you're a
loser and the next one you're god I
don't get too high I don't get too low
my friends you have to leave this
conference today and figure out for
yourself how you are gonna post on
social platforms 25 to 60 times a day
let me say it one more time that's right
and by the way I want you to do more but
I didn't want to scare you too much
Dubai
I'm not kidding 25 to 60 times a day
what does that mean that's arbitrary
numbers I could have said twenty to a
hundred I could have said 80 to 150 as
much as humanly possible I didn't say
you have to come up with 25 to 60 ideas
a day I said you have to make 25 to 60
pieces of content a day when you make an
Instagram story
maybe you save it and you go to Twitter
and you post it and you write a couple
of extra lines and now you've made two
pieces of content from one video maybe
you take that video and post it on
YouTube and write three lines of
sentence now it's a third maybe you take
a still shot and then draw over it and
it's your snap and now you're on for 25
across all platforms right I want you to
be on every platform all of them all of
them they go up they go down they go up
they go down but people don't go on
platforms because they don't have a lot
of followers on it and they feel
insecure so you stay on Instagram
because that's where you have 7,000
followers you don't want to go on
Twitter or Facebook or YouTube because
you only have 15 subscribers there and
you feel like you feel sad the person in
this room who decides to stop listening
to everybody else is the person that's
gonna win this room today right you
understand so that's it you know I hate
when people call me a motivational
speaker if you look at my content from
2011 12 13 I tried to do nothing rah-rah
or high up because I didn't want that
after I wrote crush it I'm a businessman
I'm a strategist I'm an executor I'm an
executive but over the last three years
I had to look myself in the mirror and
say I'm doing what I tell people not to
do because I don't want to be a
motivational speaker and that's how
people see me sometimes I'm not giving
away the best information I can give I
was being selfish so over the last three
years I've gone into these subject
matters if you thought that I was ever
gonna
I never thought I was gonna talk about
parents or self-esteem or entitlement if
you thought I thought five years ago
that I would ever make a video that goes
like this and yours this is for
everybody if you're 22 years old or
older and your parents give you money
you're in bad shape it's you know it's
funny I'm not I don't feel like you're a
loser
I feel like you're in trouble mentally
because what is happening is you're
getting more insecure not less you're
getting resentful of your parents and I
promise you your parents are resenting
you I never thought I was gonna make
that content but that's the content that
I watch for when I see people take
photos and by the way Dubai is a
disaster in this when I click on Dubai
every photo is private jets and Louis
Vuitton and Rolex watches I take a
throw-up on Dubai
[Applause]
all I see I don't see people that
genuinely enjoy the craftsmanship of a
Louis Vuitton bag or the fact that it's
a good shape for their day-to-day life I
see people that are so insecure that
they want to show other people that
they're doing well and they use the logo
to make themselves feel good and for
anybody who's in the crowd who doesn't
know me or is confused right now I do
not come to this amazing place to razz
on people or hurt feelings I'm here
trying to help this is the conversation
that we need across the world
good news Dubai the same things
happening in New York and LA and London
and Sydney and everywhere else in the
world that has a little bit of money in
the system we as a society have to
change the conversation no longer is it
acceptable in my opinion for Humanity to
put money on a pedestal
[Applause]
now money's fine I don't want to
demonize money go in but we have to put
happiness on a pedestal we have to do
you know how many millionaires I know
that are miserable almost all of them we
have to change this conversation let me
tell you why it's not sustainable people
want to blame suicide and all the gun
violence and all the bad stuff on social
media let me tell you guys something
there is no social media social media is
empty we fill it we're social media
social media is not making you bad
you're bad social media is exposing us
it's not changing us you're in control
not the phone not Instagram you and if
you want to get rid of the phone good
and if you want to limit your time on
Instagram good and if you want to stop
looking at the likes and post what you
actually want it or instead of exposing
your body for more likes good you
in control not them stop blaming the
machine start blaming yourself my
friends I can see it in your collective
faces you know I'm right I know I'm
right we all know it's right my question
is what are you gonna do about it
do you have the courage to take the way
you're feeling right now and leave and
go make a post without the perfect
lighting with no makeup without that
right angle and actually talk the truth
do you have that courage because I
promise you you will be much happier as
a human being if you start doing it much
enough with filters and angles and glow
lights enough with guys buying fake
watches and suits you're tricking no one
dick tricking no one you're tricking no
one this is a warfare of happiness
versus perceived happiness my friends
this is a warfare of happiness versus
perceived happiness this is the greatest
generation of perceived happy people are
going to go on vacation this holiday
season just for the Instagram photo to
send back for everybody to see gonna go
on a vacation they can't afford to make
it look like they're successful who else
is tired of this [ __ ]
[Applause]
we need to flip the world we need to
flip this both work like again it's very
important you hear this I'm a
businessman I'm trying to build huge
businesses but I like the process of
building it not what it can by me almost
every fake entrepreneur in here wants to
start a business to sell it to buy
something that's why you're not gonna
build it my friends if you're building a
business right now and thinking about
how quickly you can sell it I can
promise you you already lost and this is
all happening while the economy is
phenomenal this has been over the last
ten years when everything's easy this is
the easiest time how many people here
are entrepreneurs or startup founders
raise your hands if you are one of those
people and your business is not crushing
it during this time you suck and that's
okay
I suck at a lot of things I suck at
tennis I suck at school I suck at skiing
I'm just telling you as a friend if you
just raised your hand and you've been
doing it for three years and it's not
annihilating it right now
during the easiest time in the history
to build a business you need to really
go home and look yourself in the mirror
because let me remind you being the
number two or the number four or the
number eight at Tesla or Facebook or
Instagram made a lot more money than the
number one of your [ __ ] startup this
is about self-awareness
do you know yourself this is about
finally having the conversation that you
need to have and you need to tell your
mother or father you're done living your
life based on what they want it's time
for you to tell your spouse sister
brother husband that you're done living
your life for them hardest conversation
I do not stand up here and say that so
easily I just know it's true
I don't think it's easy I don't think I
don't think anybody's picking up the
phone call and be like hey mom
screw you it's hard I got it
I know it's hard but my friends this
starts at an early age do you know how
many everything I just talked about it's
called high school and you're still in
it we have to get out we have to get out
so that mindset is why you're not
posting I'm not I'm posting so much cuz
I'm not scared of what you're gonna say
I'm posting so much cuz I'm not scared
if it's not gonna hit the same metrics
as last time I'm posting because I have
something to say I'm posting cuz I want
to talk I'm posting cuz I love people
want to interact but the majority is
that people who say things like but I
don't know what the post are already
stuck in the judgment of the post period
end of story
the entire opportunity in your life is
writing words making pictures and making
videos for 10 websites on your phone at
the biggest scale that you can it's
happening right now this is the greatest
land grab of attention in the history of
mankind I have nothing else to say
that's there's no system I have no
products I have nothing else to say that
go do it that's it that's what I got for
you
but the mines weird the mics real quick
cuz I want to start doing Q it if you
got there's one right there and there's
one right there great guys I'm about to
go into questions it goes it goes slow
and you're probably not going to get
your question and so if you want to ask
me a question I don't cut you need to
get in a lot you better get up fast bro
run run yes faster go you're going the
wrong way dude dude you're going the
wrong way you were first to move and now
you're like 11th in line it's over there
and over there I'm gonna go into QA but
my friends I really hope you heard what
I had to say because all the tactics you
know like
I put that out for free how many people
saw two weeks ago on my birthday and put
out a 270 page deck for free raise your
hands
good most of you didn't I put out thank
you I put out a 270 page deck for free
on how you make sixty four pieces of
content today it's free google it you'll
find it somebody will share it
use the hat somebody will you'll figure
it out and if you can you're gonna lose
anyway then if you can't find my deck
you should leave you're never gonna be
able to business find the deck consume
it because that's gonna save me talking
about things that are redundant to
appear for 30 minutes let's get into the
details but I just want to tell you
Dubai thank you so much for the
hospitality thank you let's get into it
Gary how are you can you guys see if
somebody filled up that's good good good
alright so I authored a book four years
ago and basically I developed a concept
about the relationship between the
fundamentals of business and human
beings okay I'll write my book I start a
motivational speaking sales training
around the world but then I came to a
point my business was growing and then
it wasn't sustainable I wasn't making
enough money okay so I had to stop I
left Australia I ended up getting an
opportunity in Dubai and now I work for
the royal family and I advise them on
their investments okay I want to go back
to entrepreneurship but the growth
it wasn't sustainable why was the money
I was making I just couldn't like I
couldn't maybe maybe you should have
spent less I mean okay we can look look
I mean that's fair right wait wait wait
yeah it's gonna make sense I agree with
you 100% but you mean you wanted to live
a more glamorous lifestyle
Gary that all that book how much
top-line revenue was the business doing
nothing I was just 12 to 15 thousand
dollars a month right so I'm not a
brand's go I don't give a [ __ ] about
that I care about my family okay so I
had to put my business aside get my book
still sells on Amazon you like your
business Patrick Osmond by the way check
it out anyway I need to sustain my
family my brother or Mike my dad damn my
priorities they're my goals I love
that's why I put mantra pronoun aside
and I'm now this woman you miss it it's
in me yeah I love that you know you know
listen to me I came to New York and I
came to your office and security kicked
me out of your building yeah I didn't
have a meeting with you yes I was dying
to see you about three years ago dying
they wouldn't let me in so I am you yep
I respect the fact that you can tell
your energy it wasn't creepy that you
came I'm sad that I missed a DM but here
we are so let's talk about it have you
thought about starting at a side hustle
level carving out two hours a day that
doesn't exist right now so you can start
it and God willing after two years of
two or three hours a day it gives you
enough fire where you think you can then
make the flip and go there but is God
willing a strategy no god willings are
saying saying if you actually work two
hours a day every day and are smart and
bring value you may have a business okay
so but it's an important point because
what I like about you and I'm sensing it
very quickly is there's a level of
practicality and clarity I think the
most practical clear situation that
you're dealing with is you've got
something you want to do practically for
your priority but you want something for
yourself and the way to do that is to
actually do that for yourself you're
just gonna have to put in two hours a
day at first because you don't have the
luxury to put in 15 but if you nail
those two hours and by the way my first
book was just this and I have thousands
and tens of thousands of stories of
people for four years doing it for one
hour after work and then finally
something
click and they were able to make the
switch this just requires one very
difficult thing patience that's it
brother and that's your weakness it's it
kills me I know our respect that I've
seen videos of you you say it's not
about what you do from 9:00 to 5:00 it's
about with you from 5:00 to 9:00 and I
admire that and that little sentence has
has got me verified its developed
amazing things from that but the
patience thing is killing me bro
let's killin let me tell you why I'm
tricky let me tell you why I'm tricky I
just realized this very recently I'm
like all right I'm saying a lot of
things I didn't realize you had to do
all of them it's like cooking a meal you
might be good at at the hustle part you
might be good at understanding people
you might be good at giving you might be
good at taking care of people but if
you're bad at patience the whole thing
false if you're great at patience but
you don't have the work ethic it boss if
you're great at patience and the work
ethic but you treat people bad it falls
I'm like all right this is why it's
challenging you need to get all 16
ingredients right to make this actually
work and the patience for the ambitious
is the hardest do you know ambitious I
am if I didn't have patience I was in a
liquor store at 27 years old
bringing up my friends at the register I
had a patient my priority was my parents
too I wanted to build them a humongous
business for how they parented me I left
that business at 34 years old I didn't
have any money
I started vaynermedia in a conference
room in another company cuz I didn't
have enough money to pay for rent I was
patient and I'm 44 and I haven't even
started pro you got time it how old are
you 27 I'm out next I'm happy now yes
yes first I just want to say thank you
three years ago I quit my nine-to-five
job I had 3,000 germs in my bank account
and when I made that decision to quit my
job it was a lot of it because I was
consuming your content so I have a lot
to say
thank you because I quit my job and now
I have my own business it's only been
three years but it's financially healthy
I am so happy so the first thing I just
want to say thank you you mean the world
to me more than you would ever know by
the way by the way I'm sorry to
apologize there's a lot of people
thinking right now let me let me tell
you something that is very real it's not
for everybody but there's a very big
percentage of people in here that that
admiration is way more interesting than
making a hundred thousand dollars today
and if you're lucky that your DNA is
similar to mine it's about providing
value with no expectation none I love
you too people people say to me Gary
you're wrong I give all the time and I
get walked all over I go no you don't
you're not giving you're manipulating
because you're fake giving and you want
something in return
giving is only when you expect nothing
in return
I don't want your seven day trial but
then you sell me I don't want your free
course and then it actually is trying to
sell me giving is giving period okay so
yeah so I just want to first say a huge
thank you I love you so much really you
are still playing such a huge part on
how I'm running my business all of your
advice all of your content the practical
advice that you give I really my
business would not be where it's at and
it's only three years it's but it's
financially healthy and I'm so happy and
I worked my ass off in Dubai is really
hard
I'm self-funded I'm independent it's
just me
what can I answer for you okay it's been
three years I run my business here in
Dubai yes and it's getting to a point
where I just feel that Dubai doesn't
really have the infrastructure that for
an intrapreneur like me
that's it's expensive basically it's
expendable kind of business is it social
media marketing so I pretty much help
people build their own businesses and
side hustles and it's just the expensive
of running the business here in Dubai
now that it's getting to three years I
just feel that it's just weighing me
down and it's not making me feel happy
anymore move and and so my question then
is I know cuz I knew you would say that
Alex then just move but then what
happens when all of my businesses a lot
of like 80% of my businesses here might
raise money save money yeah movin do it
again you said the most important part
Alex you said you're not happy yeah yeah
and I'm not you were not happy in your
job you quit it you made yourself happy
now you're three years in and you're not
happy so move the good news for you is
unlike for a lot of people here you've
already taken a jump once do it again
and I'm happy here when I'm with my
clients doing what I love I don't care
okay that's a micro happy oh okay your
macro unhappy yeah Alex you need to move
yeah see you do by like are you how are
you Salman from Pakistan so nice to meet
you I've been following you since I was
25 26 and I just turned 30 you look
great I just didn't know after 30 what
I'll do I mean you always said 30 is the
age when you start and that I I feel
that it's I haven't done anything yet
but on the on the other side of the
country that I've done a few other a lot
of businesses whenever I reach a point
that I know I can make it okay I just
leave that thing and I move on to
another challenge to myself that's good
right but the patience thing is still
there that's not a problem I do a day
job 9 to 5 is the age 30 freaking you
out I mean
it's just I want to know how would it
start off at 30 the process that's the
thing I have not pro authority means
nothing
alright so I think 30 is bothering you
yeah that's the thing I think you find
30 means nothing all right
and just another thing on the side this
I just wanted to know like I've been on
many all of these platforms you talk
about yep it's just that I've read that
medium is the message rather than the
message you give out of course right so
I just want to know your two cents on
what do you feel about the medium itself
I believe in context for the medium but
the message is the message right so
medium is the message or the message of
the medium both well but look look you
you could sue my content we're all over
different places you've answered your
question right got it yeah
thank you you gotta you so much hello
Carrie this is Fabio kalarani from me
how are you good you well so in 2015 I
was broke I was living with my parents
with my wife right here she was sleeping
in the living room - my parents were
conservative oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
so then digital marketing saved my life
ok in 2017 I decided to give back to the
world so I created the biggest movement
of digital entrepreneurs in Italy ok
with thousands of people and they even
make it stronger with a movement called
all winners with people that go all-in
and want to make it again ok so now I'm
like you I created content every day I
like it every platform team in the
content making it for every platform
good but I would like to end my message
go out there more organically because
even if I know the algorithm of you do
maybe like I know a little bit I know
how to write
words in your conten I'm a marketer I
feel I'm going too slow I want to impact
more people and they started in Italy
because I'm Italian I got it but then I
speak other two languages impact the
world okay so how will you help like
give me another advice two things faster
two things the quickest way to not grow
faster is to want to grow faster let me
tell you why what worked for you was
something that mattered and it caught
fire now that you want to grow faster
you're trying to hack strategies to make
you grow faster in numbers the message
is getting diluted yeah because maybe I
can get the entire on creating too many
caught too much content Jerry Alec is
there I'm getting tired on you no
bombarding this social it's not bad it's
that your North Star is to grow in
numbers not to be thoughtful to come up
with new things to say my advice is stop
trying to grow faster so thank you take
my time and say things that matter yeah
without filter correct in your face
that's right that's what I do thank you
you got it Mike hi Gary my name's Nadal
I'm 15
how are you bro I'm good how are you
really well so I currently run two
businesses however there's one business
that I'm currently struggling with that
includes sports cards okay sports cards
might maybe like big in the US and
Canada however here in the UAE I don't
think anyone really collapsed nose yeah
okay so I've been trying to talk to my
friends and send some companies about
there and educate them about it however
I'm not really successful in building a
community for the niche
how long have you tried to build the
community for the niche like two months
okay
you know where I'm going right I mean
first of all you've got a obviously look
at proper football cards for this niche
right there's a much better chance
like maybe basketball definitely not
football or baseball like this is gonna
be a football market a proper football
market it will happen here if it
continues to go the way it's going
because people are making a fortune on
it and a lot of people when they get
educated that they can make more money
in sports cards than they can and
cryptocurrency and cannabis will run
towards your game you just need to stay
patient you just told me that you're
struggling after trying to do something
for eight weeks oh yeah you got it thank
you you're welcome
anything meaningful anything meaningful
takes a very very very let me get this
straight
you want to win you want to win life you
want to live a one-percent life of being
a millionaire and doing anything you
want and being happy don't you think
that should be hard and should take a
long time hey Gary how are you good how
are you super first of all I want to say
thank you for everything you've made a
lot of changing in my personality and
all they I don't know what you call like
drilling ideas yes yeah it's just been
crazy I've been working on it for long
and another thing I want to say they 180
cent yes rule it works so everybody go
for it I've been doing it for 3-4 weeks
now I've noticed not only growth but
that I can give some ideas I'm into
calisthenics so I went through and
sometimes I just say a great workout or
something like that but at another time
so I'm giving deep really good good
advices try to do a handstand or
like that the 180 strategy if you google
garyvee 180 strategy is the idea of
leave there's a saying leave your what's
your two cents on this idea ninety times
a day on Instagram you go to other
people's accounts in the things that
you're interested in look at their
content and leave a comment that's
meaningful not like them with the hope
they like you back
follow unfollow all the [ __ ] no no
meaningful comments and then you start
building meaningful relationships so
before I get into my question I'm into
making funny videos as well okay and I
have this company a combination of
calisthenics sports and funny videos and
it goes to many topics like even
parenting okay I've done
funny videos about sports and stuff and
funny videos about friends okay it goes
to many topics and I've done some videos
for companies have been trying to yeah
I'm in negotiation with a company
similar to Best Buy in the States okay
and I made three videos for you I wish
that you can I already DM do an
Instagram dirac and team garyvee I
showed you two videos I made them really
quick cuz I was coming here and it is
shitty so I can remake them okay bye and
the third scenario I haven't made it yet
but it's written and I just want to I
can't wait to send it want your advice
on it or I'll take a look in I will so
my question is how can you go into the
state of not judging yourself practice
still keep going right because I've had
it one for like a month and a half
practice I've been focusing on
calisthenics and videos frankly I want
silence in here practice but then it was
gone
practice
you got a practice you got to read the
comment and play with it
you suck you're not funny read it read
it read it now here's where it gets good
if you read the comment from somebody
saying you suck or you know or if you're
are you judging yourself or are you
getting or you struggling with the
judgment of others somebody saying it's
stupid idea that you're doing this or a
comment that's bad I mean I didn't get
anybody saying is stupid a lot of people
like in it okay but for me like
continuing the work I heard this half a
month and a half month that I've been
talking about I went through like
putting my workouts putting video is
putting funny many points out huh are
you burnt out you don't want to do it
anymore
no it's just I for some reason I slacked
and I didn't do anything I've had this
conversation with somebody and just went
why I don't know
what do you think I've been thinking of
maybe the combination of two is not good
sometimes and it's slowing me down and
I'm not putting as much content as I
want to what do you think of the
combination like putting sports and good
advice it's good funny videos good yeah
I think you might be impatient because
you went so hard for a month and a half
and the numbers didn't get to as high as
you want them by going too hard for a
month and a half right because the
reason you're asking yourself is this a
good combo is you didn't see the result
that you expected let me promise you one
way that you can consistently make
yourself unhappy having expectations I'm
gonna move thank you very much
we got the microphone up and I love it
let's do it we've got to pick up the
talk who has the microphone up the top
please start waving and ask your
question thank you love it
go ahead
hold on one second it's not working keep
talking though nope still no okay
thank you thank you Gary Thank You shade
this my name is Marie lazuli I'm the
founder of global lumen and I work a lot
with women entrepreneurs and most of
them who come to the club they never
have done a video life in their life
okay and the issue here is that they
really like their private life but they
still want to be successful in business
okay would it be your advice for all
women who are watching this video now
how can they get that confidence to
break that fear to take the phone and
make a live video in social media there
was something you said that I didn't
fully hear you were you saying that
they're scared to do it because they
want privacy yeah they go together they
go together very easily I'm the most
public private person on earth you guys
know nothing about my family I post zero
point zero about my family you look them
in the face and tell them you don't have
to post about your family and what would
be your advice for them right now to
post
she's possible what's that okay okay
okay well managing a real life and a
side hustle that they love is just about
really looking at every hour that you
spend on what it's just balanced it's
just time management it's also what's
the alternative people come to me all
the time and they say well Gary I'm
struck I can't balance my my career my
job that I have to do and my side
coaching or whatever I'm like okay then
don't then do both then do both of
course it's hard everything's [ __ ]
hard I love you too go ahead hi
I'm gonna go over here oh go ahead god
you're good hi Gary
my name is Kai hi I first of all I just
want to say thank you for living your
truth and just speaking it to everyone
and inspiring us all thank you I'm a
musician from the UK and I kind of fell
into a business here in Dubai called the
bike club and we promote restaurants
since doing the point Club we do about
six events a week we're meeting hundreds
sometimes thousands of people daily
weekly yeah and I found that I've got
lots of good ideas and I'm trying to
catch up with people that I meet and
I've also realized all the stories I
don't know if there's commend to
schedule or to help curate ideas and
content because you know as a
entrepreneur a small team it's great to
create the content but actually edited
and you know cut down and everything
like even today I've taken loads of
videos but once it's edited where do you
start to turn out the 25 that you
recommend a day
what do you post it know like do you
recommend like Anna Lee or HootSuite or
any yodelling apps to help become a team
build no I think you should open Twitter
and post a photo let me tell you - hi
where everybody screws up people look
for efficiencies where what's needed is
context my friends let me promise you
how not to do social media if you post
the same exact photo with the same exact
word - all ten of the prominent
platforms they won't act the same way
you have to write the copy and you have
to edit the content for the
psychological nature and the utilitarian
nature of the platform for the for the
31 minutes you save by hitting one
button and blasting it out you're
wasting actual growth so you would
recommend because I'm learning to be
still also and just take time to balance
so let's say it was one hour a day
general bit and post individually
okay yep whatever gets you the post you
I post my content do you know busy I am
I post it I write it I reply to you
every reply you ever got ever from Gary
B is me not an intern me yeah that's why
I have a team Gary V account and other
accounts in case we want to engage where
I'm not but if it's me it's me if I have
time you have time Chi thank you hi my
name is irina anta I want to tell you
I'm consuming your content for more than
ten years now
Wow yeah I look young but yeah I've
gotten old thank you so much honestly
that means a lot right
like think about it 10 years talk about
like you know but go ahead thank ya more
than 10 years yeah so I think you're
very special and I love you thank you
yeah I think if you have more people
listen to you their world would be a
better place you clean and you make it
motivational speaker with a very very
cool one okay thank you okay so this is
about my love to you and you always say
about giving so unto I want to give you
my present okay at present to you it's
my business and if you even like look at
it after whenever you have time bring it
baby yes
okay she's running
you can thank you now the question right
a rock so basically one yes okay awful
I mean you not because you started with
wine but anyways
it's difficult you know to get
investment cuz everyone loves to talk
about online now notes not millions of
people are getting investment offline
okay cuz it's a vision boards and
whenever a good love master
how many investors have you gone to tell
me the truth or I'll get mad about
twelve and they all saying oh if you
build online version better wealth but
everyone wants all my vision no no no
you're saying everyone you're talking
about twelve people maybe thousands
maybe thousands and maybe you should go
to people maybe you should do a little
research on google for people that
invest in things that aren't online
businesses but can I have your exact
opinion sorry this is a vision but I
love it
but do you really love it - just say - I
really love it
vision board self but it doesn't exist I
created it nobody sells vision boards
people sell vision boards nobody go to
Pinterest people sell vision boards
people sell vision board kits it's not
like that yours might be your might be
best
good alright or a some shapers I'm sure
it I love it
you're welcome
hi Gary
hi miss Mariela and I'm a first-time
business owner awesome actually I worked
for about ten years in the corporate
world I broke a lot of glass ceilings
around the world good for you especially
I said mom first let's clap it up for
her and I wanted more
so I started my own business and now I
feel that I'm stuck I love the process
the money is fine because I worked
really hard and the business is fine
it's not making a ton of money but it's
making enough for me to continue with
the process and I want to continue but I
feel that the growth is slowing down are
you Michael managing what's that are you
micromanaging I try to do that less and
less but I feel that where I'm stuck is
in my training and my learning you
yourself yes that's awesome
yeah so that's you know that's the most
solvable part of it all how well there's
something called the internet and on the
internet there's a website called Google
and YouTube and you can literally type
in anything that you think you're stuck
with and then somebody will give you
content for free yes it's I definitely
I'm always there but I find it so
overwhelming I feel that you know I know
identified that I don't have Mentors
okay so that's one thing but I am a loss
and overwhelmed of the amount of
information and my business is running
and it's more and I'm also involved so
you know what are you most unhappy about
that it's not growing no not the basin
is I feel that I can still give more and
I can still learn more I'm so hungry
good to learn more but I feel sometimes
people are patient like eight weeks 15
year old who I love you know and
sometimes they're impatient for
everybody in Dubai to collect football
cards sometimes people are impatient for
their side hustle to get big enough so
they leave sometimes people are
impatient for quenching their thirst for
learning but when you were stuck have
you ever felt stuck nope
really okay you know why why cuz I don't
judge myself haven't you been in a
situation where you just don't know what
to do every day right so what do you do
when that happened I make it up in a pic
one
I love losing I love going through the
process I learned that way every day I
have a situation
the reason I'm good at business now is
I've done so much I have such pattern
recognition I can do this but other
things happen to me all the time right
like every day I pick something and if
it goes well I'm like I knew it I picked
something it goes poorly it was D Rock's
fault I'm kidding I'm kidding I take
that loss and I keep evolving
you might also not be stuck you might
have decided you're stuck thank you so
much
how are you bro you're good you're good
oh actually you're not good what see I
was wrong
still it's still not working okay yeah
this let's just once a shout-out is
instagram tag because he forgot to
earlier no problem
yeah Gary I forgot to tell you the name
I can you go fast your long-winded
grown-up child that's my own of child
gotcha
just the quick question yes ik top yes I
know you've been shouting out by every
yes Lee where do you see it going in the
next three to five years so any confused
because at the moment obviously it's
like dancing videos and yeah like
Instagram mom she's died I feel is right
and obviously I'm just wondering like
wait where you see it going I'm no I'm
not Nostradamus okay yeah what I know is
1.5 billion people are on it right now
okay she's just saying go with it keep
going with it and see what happens is
what not what what's the alternative
what's the downside people value their
time when it's not valuable of course go
with it brilliant thank you very bad
hey Gary how are you I'm good how are
you very good
my name is Sam and I am Pro calisthenics
athlete as well cheers to the other
eight on the other side actually I used
to work as a cabin crew almost for four
years but actually I liked it only for a
few months and then I decided to start
changing after four years I left because
I loved calisthenics I loved the way
high training is going with me
everything and then almost like ten
months ago I started just like searching
how do I start on social media okay yeah
and then for now I'm just like posting
normally on Instagram and that's how
many times okay story you can say like
naturally that story you can say two or
three times per week yeah I just so
basically I started I just like both my
domain I'm starting my website soon and
literally like two to three days ago I
met all the accounts on almost all the
platforms good now I want to ask you
something actually I have I have a
problem which is like if I don't have a
plan let's say if I want to go to
Everest if I don't have a map I cannot
go to to the top that's bad yeah
that's why I take too much time to plan
my thing with your place that's the game
why because I feel like if I don't know
the way how how I would reach to the top
yeah listen to this this is why a lot of
people are not entrepreneurs your
framework is an incredible number for
executive I need you to work for me it's
unlikely that you'll build anything
successful with that much fear of the
unknown
so one of two things yes start
practicing on doing things without a map
okay or put the map down and go follow
somebody else thank you you understand
that's your only two options got it and
there is listen to me listen to me there
is nothing wrong with following somebody
else there's nothing wrong with being a
number two three four this whole
generation that everybody has to be a
founder and CEO and entrepreneur is
ludicrous it's ludicrous in the same way
that everybody should have been good and
went to college 20 years ago it's
ludicrous so if you want it so bad
ideologically you got to start going
into the forest without a map
you got a try if you're incapable you're
gonna have to take a step back and say
I'm gonna follow somebody else okay
thank you very much getting all right
they're pulling me off I'm so sorry I
love you too bye please oh my god please
guys II I've been following you for five
years
please if my advice you're like this I
can't believe you're a friend to me yo
you run my vision boards I beg you
you'll never believe this they just told
me had you been following me for six
years I could have asked you now good
good go ahead though you were very loud
before
it's okay firstly I just want to say I
have visualized this moment for so long
the last four or five years I think
you're unbelievable because of you I've
got so much more gratitude in my life
and I can't thank you enough for that
honestly so this is a really big moment
for me and I'm fighting for it and I
really appreciate you and I want to say
that I want to hook you after I talk to
you just one hug two seconds please done
thank you okay I love you
I'm new don't worry I'm staying you're
not gonna lose me now don't worry I'm
waiting you got me here we go I moved to
Abu Dhabi when I was 20 I'm now 28 I'm a
teacher here okay
I have a slight business that I'm
building before you judge me
yes I'm a life coach I don't have
everything figured out I know I don't
I'm using my experience of being an
expert to hopefully help people in X
pass in their life so you're not you're
not a light coach you're an expat coach
which I love going you know why because
you're actually an expat yes I am an
Xbox and I have found a niche where I
really want to help I like that though I
didn't have I'm looking inside for my
niece right who do you think who do you
think Gary B is I'm the person the
12-year old me was looking for yeah I
understand yep I'm a teacher full time
yep I'm trying to build Nova coach
that's my business okay from x-pac
teachers but also my energy has now been
taken away a little because I'm
obviously still teaching okay but I've
been now implementing a coaching program
into my school okay in Abu Dhabi around
building a culture of innovation and
Trust which is actually trying out to be
pretty unbelievable amazing and I'm kind
of torn between what do I do like I know
I need to leave teaching I'm incredibly
passionate person and I know I'm meant
to be doing something without coaching
or spats or building culture innovation
and Trust in schools great I'm stuck I
don't know where to put my energy though
because like right now my content is a
bit stale online because I've been
pumping my energy into teaching and also
building this culture of innovation and
Trust in my school
your actions are speaking sorry I'm like
your no your actions my actions I your
answer is what you're doing right now
yeah you're more passionate about this
culture thing because you've now
innovated and said wait a minute maybe
this is what I need to be doing but I
mean I'm extremely passionate about the
expat experience no sure you know yeah
you can tell if you heard my heart
beating now it'd be crazy I'm just so
nervous I love that you're passionate
about that but your actions are speeding
about this yeah so see this through yeah
and see where it takes you
and it's just produce content as much as
I want to make platforms coach my dear
I'm so glad we got your question in
thank you everybody does your judging
I'm myself correct yeah do six months of
this thing yeah and if it doesn't feel
good anymore start doing more expat
because I'm getting a good response from
the school and from the teachers around
creating innovation a culture of
innovation and trust because the
buzzword right now is innovation but
people are afraid to take risks so we
need to create trust in schools yep yeah
I'd only want to do I don't know why
you're judging yourself for not
finishing the expat thing when this
thing came see that through okay I know
you liked it
should I change my content online yes to
culture of innovation and Trust yep I
don't know if you heard this okay but of
course seven years I only put out
content about wine so you can do
remember that for what do I do I feel
disloyal to the galleries like yeah do
you remember that part of my story yeah
yeah so that's the answer okay so it's
okay to change it's okay I got good news
for you evolve everything's okay okay
okay thank you
come on all right goodbye thank you so
much
thank you
you